we didn't sign odell to trade him you
know i just i want to compete i want to
be legendary i just think that cats
ruined him my goal was always to be in
the hall of fame to win trophies to be
able to leave a legacy i mean this is
one of the biggest trades we've ever
seen in the history of the nfl it was
purely a football business decision john
dorsey's thanos right now
i'm very happy to have o'dell beckham as
the 17th pick in the 2019 draft nobody
else really matters i think this moment
is going to be more iconic than we all
realize the entire bar started chanting
obj the excitement is real gentlemen i
really think we're going to see the fury
unleashed
let the games begin
buyer beware and seller beware because
of the four key football positions for
the two teams involved in the odell
beckham jr transaction three of them are
now unemployed freddie kitchens has gone
in cleveland pat shurmur is gone with
the giants and john dorsey was fired
well mutual parting mutual parting my
behind he was fired on tuesday by the
cleveland browns when he declined to
have his duties dramatically curtailed
and in certain respects the otto beckham
jr trade was the epicenter of
a move that that brought down both teams
this year chris because the giants would
have been a lot better with him and the
browns weren't better with him no they
were not and i don't think odell odell
beckham jr was it's two different
spectrums here with both of these teams
i you know i don't think odell beckham
jr was first off 100 healthy uh i'll say
that just to defend him but regardless
you know yes the the browns have made
moves because of
lack of being buttoned up or
lack of maturity on and off the field as
far as just little things whether it was
play calling the way guys acted whatever
it may be way guys acted at the podium
there was just so many other issues
there in cleveland to me with the new
york giants it was all football related
and that's to me where i think the
browns organization got totally totally
blown up there at least as far as gm and
head coach because they realized like no
there's some fundamental issues here
with the giants i think hey giants brass
thought that hey we have some young
talent there's stuff to build on i just
don't think they were happy with the
head coach and that's all there was to
it so there's more work to be done in
cleveland than in new york but i would
also say i think cleveland's roster is
probably in a better spot than new york
right now too and that's where it gets
interesting as far as who gets hired
where and what happens the challenge for
the browns is to retool the roster with
leadership exactly with guys who will
hold young immature players accountable
it is something that odell beckham jr
seems to be craving he wants to have
that patriot way descend upon berea ohio
and take over the browns whether that
means josh mcdaniels as the head coach
that remains to be seen but ownership
has made it clear they are looking for
an exceptional leader as coach and i
feel like they're toying with the idea
chris of shifting to the model where the
coach is in charge and the gm or
whatever title is given to that person
is setting the table for the coach and
the coach runs the show and the wild
card in all of this is paul d podesta
the chief strategy officer who lives in
california
but is involved in setting the table for
the coaching search if they hire his guy
it goes one way if they hire somebody
else who isn't a d podesta the guy it
goes another way i think it's critical
that whether deep podesta is there or
not there everyone needs to be on the
same page you can't have this internal
friction that has characterized the
browns over the last three or four years
where you've got the football guys and
the analytics guys because when things
go sideways they blame each other no
you're exactly right they got to find
something that works that's you know
simpatico that you know the head coach
and gm are on the same page along with
they need a head coach that's you know
somewhat of a proven commodity you know
that's why you know listen i hear mike
mccarthy's name thrown out there i
understand that i get it he understands
how to run an organization things are to
get buttoned up you know i don't think
you're going to see baker mayfield and
company and everybody spouting off at
press conferences with a guy like mike
mccarthy josh mcdaniel is the same thing
i know people will say well it didn't
work for him in denver the first time as
a head coach there was a lot of issues
there i can't get into all of it but
he's still a proven commodity and
understands the everyday details of what
makes an organization successful and i
do think both of them could add great
leadership to that organization
i really wonder what the browns
organization currently thinks ownership
currently thinks of baker mayfield it's
one thing to deal with those antics when
he's great now that he is below average
and that's what he was this year
what do you really want him long-term do
you want a coach that wants him or do
you want a coach that has a different
plan i think that's part of this
intrigue as well we'll be back with more
right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports